we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's a caller who wants more
interviews with
loony people do you agree with them take
a listen
hey david this is devon from rhode
island yeah i was wondering if you would
go back to
interviewing the loonies you know all
the crazy people and
delusional people bad faith actors
because
watching you handle professionally
handle these people
really helps us normal people who aren't
naturally gifted at it who might blow up
emotionally
who don't know how to respond to the
faulty logic
watching you interact and and question
them
and then listen to their answer and take
apart their answer or even give them
credit when
you know they are right watching you do
that really helps us
uh maybe do a poll and see what other
people think yeah i mean
i really appreciate the kind words the
reason we've got gotten away from it is
sometimes the loony people are also
really annoying to schedule interviews
with like as
as loony as they are on camera they're
just as loony in the management of their
personal calendar
and to be perfectly frank i got a little
bored with it because it's like
yeah how most of us know that these
people
exist and i find that it's better
to critique their views without them
right there
screaming and going nuts it's sometimes
much more productive that way
but i'm open to doing more of the looney
interviews if people are really
interested in that it just i was
starting to get a little bored with it
and my sense was the audience maybe
didn't care for it that much
but i'm certainly willing to look at
that on today's bonus show
states that ended federal unemployment
benefits
saw no clear job gains despite what
right-wingers were claiming would happen
california is going to launch the
nation's largest free student lunch
program
but how can they afford it with their
huge budget surplus that's exactly how
and a u.s judge has upheld indiana
university's
vaccine requirement which applies in the
fall
to students faculty and staff
we will talk about why and we will talk
about what we are likely to see
in other challenges against college
vaccine requirements
all of that and even more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com we
will see you there or tomorrow